So the first question that you
may be asking in the audience
today is, who am I?
I am a marine community
ecologist by training.
I'm passionate about using math
to understand natural systems
and using RStudio to do it.
My current work is looking
at marine communities
and how they're responding
to climate change.
And so even though I'm battling
a lot of imposter syndrome
to say this in front of the room
full of incredible R RStudio
users in front of me today.
I am a data scientist.
Thank you.
And as a data scientist
and as a marine scientist,
I'm very familiar with
walking into rooms
and being one of
very few, if any.
In fact, I am one of the 3%.
Data suggests that fewer than 3%
of data scientists
are women of color.
And while I humbly stand before
you all today pronouncing this
as a success story,
there were a number
of trials and tribulations
along the way.
And so I want to
talk a little bit
about how I was almost lost on
this journey to data science
and how I almost was not
standing in front of you
all today giving
this presentation.
When I started
graduate school, I
felt like the corner
of this photo,
of this beautiful
illustration by Alison Horst.
I was in my own little corner.
I didn't know what I was doing.
It felt like it was
a lot of rainy days,
and I was especially
weighed down
by the exclusivity I
felt about data science.
It felt like a tool
that I was using,
but it didn't feel like a
community that I was a part of.
I was also weighed down
by the historic exclusion
of minority STEM
professionals that I
felt very much so in academia.
And I also was stunned at the
lack of action and support
from my institution and
from academia in general
in the wake of a call
for social justice
and reform and
equity in our field.
And so I lost my spark.
It felt like I didn't know why I
was in graduate school anymore.
It felt like I didn't know why
I was using these tools anymore.
But open science saved me.
It opened this
landscape of community.
It opened this opportunity
for me to find myself again.
And I found community in
RStudio and its users.
I also participated in the
Openscapes champions program
and it changed my
workflow radically.
And I discovered
once again my passion
for data science education
and also for engaging
other students as well.
And so I may have
said two words already
that you're unfamiliar with, so
I want to define them quickly.
The first is open science,
and the second is Openscapes.
So open science is the
tools and the practices
that enable all
of us to have more
reproducible, transparent and
inclusive practices for data
intensive science.
And so when we're
talking about tools,
we're talking about these open
source softwares and practices
that we're using,
for example, github,
and we talk about the practices
as well and the communities
that exist around these tools,
for example, RStudio community.
And if you had the pleasure of
hearing this morning's keynote,
you learned a little
bit about Openscapes.
And so Openscapes helps
researchers reimagine
data intensive science
and also to develop
the skills to cultivate
collaborative and inclusive
teams.
And they do that in
two ways in particular.
The first is through the Openscapes
champions program,
which I was a
participant in, which
is an open science mentorship
program for science teams.
And the second is through
cultivating the Openscapes
mindset, which is a community
building framework to support
the transition to open science.
And it relies on
these three principles
that turn into a cycle
of community building.
The first is to
empower research teams.
The second is to
amplify leaders,
and the third is
to engage mentors.
And so when I participated
in the Openscapes champions
program, it changed my life.
I was so excited to see that
new, beautiful landscape
of open science and
collaboration that existed.
And so I asked two questions
after my participation
in Openscapes when we were
checking in a few months later.
The first was, why had I never
heard of open science before?
And the second was, how
do I get more students
like myself to learn
about open science
before they fall through
the cracks in this pipeline?
And so that conversation,
those questions
turned into a dialogue.
And that dialogue has now turned
into a long term collaboration
with Openscapes to
support and explore
how we can support
students from historically
excluded backgrounds on their
journeys to data science.
And more than that,
it also connected me
with an incredible
community of people
with similar, similarly
motivated by their values,
by valuing diversity, inclusion,
transparency and collaboration.
And so I was all of a
sudden exposed to all
of these incredible
resources, especially the R and
RStudio community.
And I learned what
it had to offer.
And so I went from an
outsider and believing
that data science
was just a tool
that I used to do my work to.
Now, being a participant
in the change
that I'm hoping to see in
our data science communities.
And so when we've been
reflecting about how
I made it to this point.
And how I'm standing in
front of you all today,
I thought about a formula
for the success that's
led to this point, the first
point being values in action.
The second being investment
aligned with these values,
and the third being an Openscapes
mindset at all levels.
And I'll take a moment
to go into each of these.
The first is values in action.
It was incredibly
refreshing for me
to participate and be a part
of communities that showed me
that they were
walking their talk.
Not only is inclusivity and
transparency and collaboration
a part of the work
that RStudio is doing,
but it's also a part of the
community and the people
who are a part of it.
Some examples of that include
my users and our Ladies.
Also being able to
see and experience
the authentic leadership within
the open science community,
in particular with Openscapes.
In our studio,
we've had the chance
to hear from so many of
the incredible developers
and leaders who are
part of these teams,
and it's refreshing
to see how open they
are to hearing our concerns.
How much of part of they
are part of this community?
And it matters that all of
us are working together.
And lastly, action with
a sense of urgency.
I don't think any of
us would be here today
if we didn't believe that
RStudio community was going
to make this a safe place.
This an example of that is
the code of conduct and COVID
policies for this conference.
This is my very first time
giving a non-academic talk.
This is my very
first time talking
about diversity and equity,
and that's very scary for me.
But I knew that the
place that I wanted
to do it for the first time
was at RStudio conference.
And that to me is
a testament to what
this community is capable of.
The next is investing in
those community values.
And I think that there are
two ways that the open science
community has demonstrated
this to me in particular.
And the first is prioritizing
compensating people
for their time, their effort,
and their contributions
to safer spaces for all of us.
My work with Openscapes
was the very first time
in my career of working
on diversity, equity
and inclusion, and over six
years where I was compensated
for the work that I was doing.
And to me, it made
me less stressed
that this was a side project
that I was passionate about
and showed me that I could
prioritize this in my life
and that it was a
priority to the community
that I was serving as well.
And it made all the difference.
The next is lowering the
barriers for participation
and engagement.
The reason I'm standing
before you all today
is that I'm a participant in
the R RStudio diversity Scholars
Program that made it
possible for me to be here
and to participate in workshops
and present to you all today.
And I think it's just one
example of the many ways
that RStudio community is
committed to making sure
that we get a lot of
people in these rooms,
having these conversations.
Additionally, the
resource guides
and the openness of this
community to learners
at every level is
an incredible asset
to being able to bring people
from all types of backgrounds
into our data
science communities.
I think a great example
of that is if you've ever
been searching for the answer
to a question that you have,
you've probably stumbled upon
the rstudio blog as well.
And lastly is the open
scapes mindset at all levels.
As I mentioned, there are
three tiers to this flywheel.
The first is empowering
research teams,
the second being amplifying
leaders, and the third
being engaged mentors.
And ultimately, what this is
building is a community where
at every level, regardless
of hierarchy or leadership
structure, that all
of us are committed
to building community.
All of us are committed
to mentoring and working
with one another.
And ultimately, we're able
to build collaboration
and mentorship not only within
our organizations, but beyond.
It makes our work more
collaborative, more inclusive.
It makes it kinder and
more efficient as well.
And ultimately, building
community with the Openscapes
mindset means that
you're not alone,
regardless of if you
just join the team
or you're well into your work.
This is a way for us to
collaborate and learn
with one another and
no one has to try
to fix anything by themselves.
And we can all
experience and enjoy
the landscape open
science has to offer.
So what does it look
like when we do the work?
What does it look like when
all of these principles
are in place?
What does it look like when
we put this formula together?
Values and action.
Investment aligned
with these values.
And lastly, an Openscapes
mindset at all levels.
It looks like going
from learner to teacher.
This is a photo of me teaching
my very first open science
lecture to a cohort of
Openscapes champions
that participated after I did.
It looks like expanding our
open data and open principles
to communities beyond our own.
And I was able to host an event.
In other communities
that I'm a part of.
This year
I hosted in a data
science mixer for Black
and marine science and
other organizations
that I'm a member of.
And I was able to bring together
quantitative marine scientists
to build community and
talk about open science
and explore how we can
collaborate with one another.
And lastly, it looks like
building the better future
that we want to see.
This is from my colleague
and I being recipients
of the code for science and
society event fund grant, where
in the spring of
2023 we're going
to be bringing a
Pathways to open science
programming to students from
historically Black colleges
and universities.
HbCUs, of which I am an alum.
Thank you.
And so all of that to say
that a more equitable future
for our field is
possible, but it's
time for us to do the work.
And so I'm leaving
everyone in this room today
with three action
items and three ways
to begin those conversations.
And the first is the
center, the voices of those
we work to support and include.
This is a time to listen.
This is a time to amplify.
It's not a time to do
anything more than that.
Also to ask hard questions
in the rooms where you do
have a voice.
Look at your organization,
at your hiring structure,
at your onboarding
process, and ask yourself
some of those questions.
Where are people falling
through the cracks?
Where can we do better?
What needs to happen for
our team to include everyone
at any level?
And lastly, be the
community member
who you want to meet at the
beginning of your journey.
Had I not met Julie, I would
not be standing in front of you
all today.
And so I encourage
you all to visit Julie
and also to continue
to perpetuate community
and provide this inclusive space
at every level of leadership,
at every level of engagement,
so that no matter what
angle someone enters RStudio
community at or enters the data
science community, yet
that they feel included
and that we're ready
to work together.
And so while I stand before
you all today as one of few,
I strongly believe that
leveraging our community,
I can be one of many.
And with that, I would like to
sincerely Thank and acknowledge
everyone who made presenting
in front of you all today
possible.
So I'd like to thank Julie
and the Openscapes team.
I'd like to thank the
RStudio diversity scholars,
and I would also
like to thank Micah
for in my support
system who made sure,
even though I just took my PhD
comprehensive exams last week
and I passed that I was still...
Thank you.
That I was still able and ready
to be standing in front of you
all today and give
this presentation.
And so with that, I'm happy
to take any questions.
I'd love to connect
with you all.
I'd love to work with you all.
And I'm and I'm ready
to take any questions.
Thank you.